hello everyone and welcome to the tie
breaks of the
ftx crypto cup knockouts uh
quarterfinals it's hikarna kamura versus
magnus carlsen and
this is now blitz territory so after the
four rapid games have been played now
the result was a draw uh he hikaru
started by winning the first game then
magnus retaliated with the black pieces
in game two
and then game three and game four ended
in a draw now game five which is the
first game of the blitz section ended by
magnus
winning with the white pieces it was a
pretty straightforward win in a really
tough situation hikaru blundered a piece
but now
hikaru has the white pieces uh it's
blitz game everything in it
everything is in his hands if he can win
this uh then he will force
armageddon if not then magnus proceeds
to the semifinals and hikaru is out of
the
ftx crypto cup so without further ado
let's check it out and let's see who
will uh get closer to winning that uh
well uh almost 100 000 in bitcoin
so nakamura with the white pieces opens
with e4
we have e5 by magnus knight to f3
knights to c6 and
bishop to b5 again the real opus is on
the board and again we have the
berlin defense so knight to f6 uh we
have d3 and the bishop to c5
now we have c3 in the now both players
just castle uh that's not castles uh
castles by black castles by white and
now
d6 we have rook to e1 and now
a6 chasing away this bishop with bishop
to a4
uh and now uh we have the shabby back to
a7
uh we have h3 by hikaru taking away the
g4 square from carlson's pieces
uh and the knights the e7 now uh we have
knight b
the d2 and the knight the g6 so this is
all been played before nothing out of
the ordinary
knights to f1 the knight now now coming
to g3 or e3 depending on what black
plays
and now d5 the very early d5 magnus
asking i'm already leading the match
if you want you can accept this and we
can
uh we can play some serious chess and
here uh known moves in this position are
bishop to g5 and the knight uh
to g3 however here uh hikaru plays queen
to e2 and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so let's
see
how magnus deals with this uh he starts
with c6
uh and okay we have bishop to d2
continuing development and now comes
rook to e8 uh we have rook 8 to d1 uh by
hikaru and then now comes
h6 uh we have knight to g3 and
now bishop to e6 so both players just
are developing their pieces to optimal
squares
we have queen to f1 by hikaru and now
comes
b5 grabbing more space on the queen side
bishop to b3 and now queen to c7 now the
rooks are connected and he can bring the
other rook into the game as well
uh hikaru here trades one and once on d5
we have c captures on d5 and now d4 and
here he carries basically hoping
that magnus trades uh this pawn for pawn
but magnus of course not interested in
that he
uh advances the pawn to e4 and now
hikaru's position
is already very very difficult to play
by playing this e4 move this diagonal
opened up
and that's a huge trouble knights to h2
and now
bishop back to b8 instantly going for
this uh
queen bishop battery now this knight if
it ever
leaves then queen captures and h2 will
just be checkmate so hikaru has to be
very careful here
he starts by playing queen to e2 he
frees up one of uh
df1 square for the knight so the knight
on f1 will control nicely
both of these squares and defend from
any future checkmate threats so here at
knights the f4
uh basically forcing a trade because if
you leave the knight here that's just uh
too powerful a piece so bishop captures
we have queen captures on f4 and now
this knight comes to f1 now this knight
can move as this knight controls both of
these
squares so here queen to g5 now
making room for the other knight on f4
and hikaru goes king to h1
uh we have f sorry we have bishop to b6
now
magnus wants to bring this rook into the
game as well and queen to d2 now hikaru
has to offer a queen trade
and hope to do something here his
position is very bad and it's a terrible
position to be in
since magnus already won the first game
and now hikaru has to win to force tie
breaks
in the form of the the armageddon game
so here
bishop to f4 magnus blocks this forces
the queen away queen to c2 and now
rook a to c8 we have knights to e2 now
hoping to eliminate this dark square
bishop but magnus just brings it back
now the rook has been developed and we
can bring the bishop
all the way back so here queen to d2
again
hikaru offers a queen trait and again
magnus declines of course you don't want
to trade queens
the power of black's position is in the
potential to attack so here we have king
back to g1
getting away from the h file also the f2
pawn is under attack so here
hikaru defends it with the king and now
comes knight the h5 so
uh more and more pieces are starting to
gather around
hikaru's king we have a5 by hikaru
the position is already very bad that
there are no good moves on the king side
and
none of the pieces can really move so
here hikaru wants to make a breakthrough
here on the queen side and maybe get
this rook into the game via this a6
square
so here we have f5 by magnus now
starting with the idea of f4 and f3
and hikaru continues with his plan we
have a capture sun b5 and magnus
recaptures
you don't really need to do this you
could also just start advancing the pawn
but
safety first because he doesn't need to
risk anything he already won the first
game rook to a1
preparing this very nice rook lift and
now magnus goes for
f4 we have rooked a6 going after the
bishop here
the idea is if you play something weird
and i'm gonna show it because it's very
nice for example if magnus just
continues the attack
then we go into this very very cool line
of rook captures
rook captures and bishop captures now
preparing to win this rook with
check which would also win this rook so
rook the e8
and now knight eat the g3 let's say we
try and save the knight
now we capture here then the knight
moves knight to h2 and now we can
grab some material here captures
captures and captures now we're
threatening to capture this with the
knight because
i know none of you forgot about our good
friend the bishop on b8
so here knights the g4 would be played
in h5 and this is how black
wins so it takes a while but uh
maybe not uh maybe you don't need to
risk too much uh we we could even
go for some like rook captures on e4 h
capture sanji for
queen captures on g2 we could trade here
g captures on h3 trade absolutely
everything here and now after this let's
say now we trade everything captures
captures captures and captures
and now black still wins this because
well he has two pawns and the bishop and
the king will
very easily pick off all of these pawns
and the the y king is simply too far
away
but just in case you were wondering i
know i know you guys really enjoy when i
showed these uh hypothetical lines
so instead magnus just placed rook c to
d8 and now says yeah this is
this is doing nothing because now the
rook defends the d5 pawn as well and you
will not have bishop captures on d5
so now hikaru plays f3 that prevents
magnus from pushing f3 but now magnus
says okay e3 is just as good
we have queen to d1 and now uh the
position is just completely lost but
uh for the fun of it feel free to pause
the video here in the window game for
magnus
end the quarterfinal match while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on playing
pretty much any move in the position
because black's position is just that
good and for those of you who
would just want to enjoy the show and uh
have decided to play the exact same
magnus played then congratulations it's
bishop captures uh on h3 bishop captures
an h3 is one of my favorite
moves in chess always brings back
memories of
gerganitza versus tal if you remember
that game if you don't
do check it out i will put a link to it
in the description below just absolute
madness
it's a pretty old video you know back
when my videos were still at only
30 frames per second but it's it's
really worth checking out the game if
you haven't seen it
so bishop captures an h3 and now uh
capturing the bishop
is just game over queen f2 checking h1
uh we're going to capture this one with
check and now everything just falls
apart king h2 and that's it knight g3
we're threatening checkmate here so we'd
have to capture here but it doesn't
really help just captures with
check king g1 and now we play check king
h1 and g2 checkmate as the bishop still
covers
the h2 square do not forget about the
bishop
so here uh after this bishop captures an
h3 he carl played rook to g6
but this also doesn't help him all that
much bishop to f5
uh sorry the wrong bishop
i know that the bishop coming to f5 is
crucial here i just picked up the wrong
bishop it happens
uh so here bishop f5 attacking the rook
here and
there is now nothing you can do uh
hikaru
tried with bishop to c2 but that's just
a game over magnus captured on c2
and he was in this position anmo 37 that
hikaru nakamura resigned to the game
and with it uh his chances of winning
the quarter-final match against magnus
carlsen
uh you cannot capture him because the
rook hangs and that's it
if you don't capture there's really no
other move there's the queen has no
squares uh you you could try something
like queen to a1
but then just queen f2 check and you
know you you play pretty much anything
white is down simply too much material
and the position is just
uh just terrible yeah after bishop
captures and see do he carry resigned
and
an excellent victory for magnus carlsen
who really
did a fine job bouncing back since he
car won the first game then magnus had
to win
the second game and then you know uh but
when it comes to blitz games
even though hikaru is the highest rated
blitz player in the world
uh and should be the favorite magnus it
didn't really seem like
he had a too too uh hard of a time uh
winning both of the games uh against
hikaru uh but yeah i mean you can't you
can't win them all
so tough break for hikaru and
congratulations to magnus on winning
this match
uh i would like to thank roberto gomez
uh gigi ikea
sean ellis uh ryan yaglovsky and jordan
michelan
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day